this is a Fox News Alert the text of the
Senate's border Bill finally released
and Lead negotiator Senator lenford just
offended it on Fox and Friends with
Brian last hour mark Meredith is live in
Washington with a preview of what is in
the bill and Mark you know a lot of
lawmakers who've already criticized it
are now actually getting a look at it
Steve asley and Brian Lawrence good
morning friends you're right lawmakers
have some reading to do with this
comprehensive foreign aid and border
security package which was just released
over night some Senators have been
working on this for months but it's not
clear if it's really going to ever make
it out of the Senate so what are we
talking about here we're talking about
$8 billion to cover a variety of
different things for foreign aid we're
talking about specific money to go
towards Ukraine as well as 14 billion to
Israel 2 billion to help with Central
Command as it's carrying out operations
near the Red Sea in the Gulf of Aiden
and also additional money to help the
folks in Gaza 10 billion in humanitarian
aid but border security that's the big
controversy this morning Under The
Proposal it would have a mandatory
shutdown of the US border if daily
averages of 5,000 people or more would
be encountered over a weekly period so
the idea would be this would trigger the
response to shut down the Border
automatically it would also change the
current Catch and Release policies in
place as well as create a new border
emergency Authority while also trying to
get more people to help with the federal
government's efforts to control the
Border we heard from one of the key
architects of this proposal within the
last 30 minutes Senator James Lakeford
of
Oklahoma we've got a be able to have
something that mandatorily deports
everyone rather than actually releases
everyone that's what this does some
people are thinking that this is somehow
like counting 5,000 people in every day
and releasing them that that's absurd we
change the Asylum laws we increase
detention beds we double the deportation
flights uh we uh add ankle monitors for
people that are actually coming through
that do these family groups that come
through so we can track any individual
that when we don't have capacity there's
all the things that we build into this
to make this a much stronger system gaps
that are in the law get closed in this
structure we are also hearing from the
White House about this proposal the
President says this is both tough and
fair when it comes to changes for border
security he now wants Congress to pass
this quickly and have it reach his desk
but there are plenty of indications that
that may not happen anytime soon because
as Steve mentioned even before this
legislation was released we heard from
lawmakers who vowed to do all they could
to prevent it from going forward and
overnight it was the house Speaker Mike
Johnson who made it clear he's no fan of
what's going on he posted I've seen
enough this bill is even worse than we
expected and won't come close to ending
the Border catastrophe the president has
created as the lead Democrat negotiator
proclaimed under this legislation the
Border never closes if this bill reaches
the house it will be dead on arrival and
it's not just Republicans in the house
that have been speaking up we have heard
from some of the at least one Democratic
senator who says he's got real
reservations about this saying it
believes it goes too closer to what the
Trump era immigration policies were so
so Steve anley briyan and Lawrence
you're seeing a real debate play out
here at the same time this morning just
hours after this bill came out and
whether or not it actually is able to be
moved forward that is the question there
is some procedural action happening
about Wednesday I believe of this week
guys clure vote all right Mark thank you
very
much um great job on the interview Brian
because it gave us opportunity to get
some stuff yeah I my goal was to let him
talk to explain it because now now we're
going to debate it and I think that's
important because you got to know where
the folks stand on the issue listen a
lot of folks me and the senator from the
same homestown of Garland Texas a lot of
folks proud of him um but it's not
personal and I I took um with a lot of
things in the interview the first is the
The Catch and Release policy he says
it's not in there it's right here in in
in the bill right here and he says it's
not catching release because of the
monitors as well well the monitors are
monitored by a third party company and
these people take this these monitors
off all the time just as Chicago just as
Minnesota uh when you have criminals
doing it the other thing he talked about
about and Brian Prest him on is the
podus emergency order he says look the
only way he can do that yeah it's in the
bill that he can declare emergency but
those are only special cases uh when
there's a hurricane or something like
that have y'all been following the Biden
Administration they want to declare
climate emergency Healthcare emergency
there's there's a new emergency for
everything I don't trust that the third
thinge is when it comes to the Asylum
officers and he didn't really touch on
this it used to be with a federal judge
the Asylum officers are placed under the
department of home land security meaning
Alejandro mayorcas would be the boss of
that I'm not sure I want the person to
terminy the immigration law under the
Department of Homeland Security and not
in the judge um there's going to be a
lot of reaction on this but he he didn't
touch on those specifics and move well
the Democrats wanted this uh they wanted
money funding for Ukraine um in this is
also funding for Israel and Republicans
said before we do that we're also
attaching this border issue because we
have a major problem down on our
Southern border so as you were saying in
the first hour they're not going to get
everything they want Senator Langford
was saying once this moves forward and
we vote on it then we can move forward
with changing things and negotiating and
trying to work together at a bipartisan
level right and I thought I thought he
did a really good job explaining his
point of view and here's the thing it's
bipartisan so it's like the Republicans
aren't going to get everything they want
Democrats aren't going to get everything
they want he did say he had a number of
Senators who were backing him up but
ultimately there's so much
disinformation out there because it's an
election year and both sides are
essentially running on it and here we
have a sound bite from the interview
with Brian and you can find the entire
interview it's terrific at
foxandfriends.com where he talks a
little bit about the number of people in
his own party who were slamming the bill
before they even looked at it watch
this the key aspect of this again is are
we as Republicans going to have press
conferences and compl PL the borders bad
and then intentionally leave it open
after the worst month in American
history in December now we've got to
actually determine are we going to just
complain about things or we going to
actually address and to change as many
things as we can if we have the shot and
it's amazing to me if if I go back two
months ago and say we had the shot under
a Democrat president to dramatically
increase detention beds deportation
flights lock down the border to be able
to change the Asylum laws to be able to
accelerate the process no one would have
believed it and now no one actually
wants to be able to fix it and says I
don't want to even debate it I don't
want to discuss it we have to decide as
Republicans what are we going to
actually do about the Border leave it
open or actually leave it closed I think
one of the thing the big the greatest
hurdle he has number one election year
just reality number two is Jo Joe Biden
is so bad on the border he's been so I I
think it's almost impeachable what he's
allowed to happen we have about 8
million people say 18 million here
illegally if you add in the Goda ways
and now all of a sudden he goes yeah
I'll sign off on it and they go wait a
second what do you mean to sign off on
it you don't even know what's in it and
also I know the tone and Tanner of the
White House in these meetings they were
against everything they were they were
worse than Senor Murphy Murphy had to
bring along the White House who just
wanted just to let everything happen the
way it was happening they still have no
problem with mayorcas so I worry about
anything to do with discretion and this
President and I'm not saying it's 2020 I
would be worried but now in 2024 I'm
extremely concerned I have no faith that
it'll Implement things that's why it's
got to be airtight and I do worry about
the interaction if you give border
patrol uh their DRS they know how to do
it so but if they are pressured by their
bosses you let these people in that's
what worries me and to your point about
Chris Murphy he there's a tweet up right
now of Chris Murphy talking about that
the Border never closes so you got the
person who was the lead negotiator on
the left and on the right saying two
different things you got the senator
from Oklahoma saying look the Border
closes Murphy saying it doesn't close
which is it I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley aart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling
analysis